hey guys justin here with a gamespot
news update it looks like mario kart 8
has some substantial dlc coming your way
soon starting in november the game will
get new characters tracks and carts
featuring content from many of
Nintendo's other franchises including
The Legend of Zelda f0 and animal
crossing this content will come in the
form of 2 DLC packs each of which
consists of three characters for
vehicles and eight tracks some new and
some old some of the new tracks will be
set in Zelda and Animal Crossing locales
while Wario's gold mine from Mario Kart
we will also make a return the first of
the two packs The Legend of Zelda will
be coming in November and includes link
Tanooki Mario and cat peaches characters
as well as the Blue Falcon cart from
f-zero the second pack the Animal
Crossing pack comes in may and will
include the villager Isabel and dry
Bowser by buying both packs in a bundle
you'll also get eight different colors
for Yoshi and shy guy for more
information on some of the upcoming
tracks and vehicles you'll get to play
with stay tuned to gamespot com